dans quelques instants clair combien va
me rejoindre sur ce plateau on va parler
de la semaine de l'emploi qui démarre ce
vendredi 15 février mais d'avoir donc de
retour sur la mobilisation des salariés
c'était aujourd'hui au technocentre
renault à guyancourt
carlos ghosn veut gelé 30 % de sa
rémunération
renault n'échappe pas à la crise en 2012
le bénéfice net de la firme a baissé de
plus de 15% mais avec une plus value de
924 millions d'euros le pdg de la marque
au losange s'est donc présenté au
technocentre de guyancourt face à des
salariés excédés
c'est une provocation pour les salariés
de cette entreprise 30 % de salaire en
moins et en part pas en moins c'est une
partie de son salaire qui est gelé sur
les quatre ans qui viennent
si on retirait 30% aux salariés même du
technocentre ou des usines on ne
pourrait plus vivre
selon le quotidien les échos cette somme
avoisinerait les 430 mille euros mais
carlos ghosn resterait assuré de
percevoir plus de 2 millions d'euros
pour 2012 le versement n'interviendra
qu'en 2016 la condition que l'accord de
compétitivité soit validé par les
syndicats est appliqué à la lettre
c'est un chantage même pas de pression
c'est un chantage si vous signez pas
d'accord je ferme des usines c'est
carrément du chantage pour les
organisations syndicales donc la cgt
elle refuse chantage elle dit on peut
faire de la compétitivité mais autrement
pas avec un accord comme ça environ 300
salariés dont des ouvriers ce lien de
lardy étaient réunis devant
l'amphithéâtre où se tenait la réunion
avec carlos ghosn
suite à l'annoncé de carlos ghosn les
syndicats ne comptent pas en rester là
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des représentants
cgt de la marque doit se réunir demain à
paris vendredi 15 février pour envisager
d'éventuelles manifestations la semaine
prochaine et clariant bière bonsoir nous
avait rejoints pour cette chronique et
qu'on se soit on va parler de la semaine
de l'emploi exactement saint quentin en
yvelines se mobilisent c'est le slogan
de la semaine de l'emploi qui se déroule
du 15 au 23 février et on compte plus
d'une vingtaine de partenaires de
l'opération qui qui vont participer à
cet événement dont le but est d'aider
les chômeurs à trouver un emploi mais
également les entreprises à conserver
leurs salariés
pour nous en parler nous recevons jean
luc romero bonjour vous êtes directeur
de la maison d'entreprise et christine
villa machin dont présidente de la
commission emploi prévention insertion à
la communauté d'agglomération
alors madame vilain donc la semaine de
l'emploi entame sa dix septième édition
on peut dire que c'est devenu un peu un
événement incontournable dans we sa
devenu un événement incontournable qui
s'enrichit d'année en année avec les
différents partenariats qui s'étendent
avec les liens qu'on a pu tisser de plus
en plus avec le monde de l'entreprise
alors vous y vous attendez beaucoup de
monde que ce soit en terme de public
mais aussi les entreprises qui seront
présents au forum du recrutement j'ai
dit oui on attend du monde on a des
entreprises qui s'inscrivent encore on
parlait tout à l'heure
jusqu'au dernier moment des ours oui
c'est plutôt bon signe c'est plutôt bon
signe et on générale des entreprises qui
viennent avec des postes à pourvoir
donc cette cette semaine de l'emploi
c'est offrir au public un maximum de
rencontres de possibilités de rencontres
avec les entreprises avec les
partenaires de l'emploi et de
l'insertion vers l'emploi
et puis faire connaître les outils du
territoire aussi parce que il ya cette
rencontre incontournable mais il ya tout
le travail qui se fait tout au long de
l'année justement ses outils ses
partenaires il participe donc tous à 7 à
cet événement et l'idée c'est un peu que
chacun amène son action son activité et
son public
chacun amène son action les publics ils
sont ils sont variés chacun a un type
d'intervention
aussi bien les médiathèques parce
qu'elles sont un pôle ressources ou les
demandeurs d'emploi peuvent trouver de
l'information on à la cité des métiers
qui depuis deux ans a pris toute sa
place et permet aussi à travers des
ateliers aux gens de préparer leurs
entretiens
dire qu'on peut préparer l'entretien
qu'on aura au cours d'un forum avec un
recruteur et ça c'est aussi donner de
l'assurance aux demandeurs pour
faciliter ces entretiens
on a le club face qui travaillent avec
des collégiens de 3e on a voilà tout
cela fait la richesse de cette large
public un large public oui alors je
public
alors monsieur ayrault nous vous
participez avec la maison d'entreprise à
cet événement vous proposez des assises
pour les entreprises c'est un public
finalement différences les plus pour les
demandeurs d'emploi mais bien pour les
entreprises dont les assises
ma font partie de la semaine de l'emploi
mais s'adresse plus particulièrement aux
entreprises du territoire de saint
quentin
l'idée effectivement c'était d'avoir
surtout de cette semaine comme le
rappelait christine ville un certain
nombre d'actions qui s'adresse à la fois
aux personnes en recherche d'emploi vous
institutionnel aussi par ailleurs et
également aux entreprises donc les
assises sont un moment majeur dans cette
semaine puisque on essaie de mobiliser
les entreprises du territoire qu'elle
soit d'ailleurs dans une logique de
recrutement ou non mais l'idée est de de
la porter à la fois de l'information et
puis pour nous de l'échangé avec les
dirigeants d'entreprises concernées sur
d'éventuelles problématique que qu'ils
peuvent rencontrer dans le cadre de
recrutements futurs basculer le but
c'est un peu de leur expliquer comment
pérenniser l'emploi
cette année c'est ça absolument le sujet
tourne autour du maintien de l'emploi en
entreprise dans un contexte économique
un peu compliqué contexte qui qui dure
maintenant depuis quelques années et on
sait que que le problème est double
c'est des cons à la fois pour les
entreprises un problème de carnet de
commandes d'un très clairement avec des
difficultés de prévisions c'est que
beaucoup d'entre eux est aujourd'hui de
ses dirigeants n'ont pas de perspective
à moyen ou long terme donc c'est quand
même assez inquiète elle alors pour
poser un implant de compétitivité non à
la renault alors posé directement en
tous les cas ça fera partie des sujets
qui seront abordés puisque nous aurons
parmi les intervenants nous aurons
également des des représentants de
l'état puisque
madame coulanges la représentante de la
direccte sera présenté et présentera à
cette occasion un certain nombre de
mesures dont le contrat de génération
dont on parle beaucoup actuellement
donc effectivement les assises
permettront l'espère aussi de faire la
promotion d'un certain nombre de mesures
économiques pour favoriser le
recrutement qui aujourd'hui compliquée
au lait de membres donc du gouvernement
vous allez recevoir aussi des dirigeants
qui vont donner leurs expériences bien
sûr qu'est ce qu'ils vont proposer alors
à la fois pour l'intérêt pour nous
d'avoir cette table ronde avec des
dirigeants d'entreprise il est mêlé
double il est d'abord de leur de les
informer de certains de mu on en a parlé
mais aussi de les écouter de leur donner
un temps de parole pour que eux aussi
nous fasse nous fassent part de leurs
difficultés ou de leurs souhaits de
leurs attentes sur un certain nombre de
sujets sur lesquels on pourrait en tant
que collectivité territoriale ou alors
pour les acteurs institutionnels qui
seront présents aux sujets sur lesquels
on pourrait les agréent viennois leurs
équipes artistiques ces participants qui
sont des tpe sans vraiment les toutes
petites entreprises de pme ou même des
grands groupes qui peuvent venir
alors on s'est dit que les grands
groupes ils ont leurs services
juridiques qui savent gérer très bien
tout ça oui mais la problématique est
parfois la même salle et je pense que
on parlait de carnet de commandes mais
il ya un autre aspect de l'emploi
aujourd'hui qui est compliqué c'est
l'adéquation entre l'offre et la demande
on sait que certaines entreprises
paradoxalement aurait peut-être des
besoins de recrutement mais n'arrivent
pas forcément à satisfaire ses demandes
parce que l'on sait que que l'offre ne
correspond pas toujours tout à fait donc
s'intéressant également d'avoir aussi le
discours et le remonter l'information de
ses dirigeants d'entreprises et les
assises sont aussi un moment d'échangés
important parce que on n'a pas parlé de
l'université mme à l'université sera
aussi présenté un acteur incontournable
de ces assises
donc ça permet vraiment d'un moment
donné d'avoir de se poser et d'échanger
sur des problématiques communes et pour
essayer de trouver des solutions à court
et moyen terme
je rebondis vous parlez de l'université
c'est qu'il ya en fait finalement trois
publics entreprises demandeurs d'emploi
également les scolaires il ya pas mal de
dates on a le forum de formations
métiers qui a lieu à guyancourt et qui
permet à cette période où les jeunes
travaillent beaucoup sur leur
orientation scolaire de rencontrer les
centres de formation à guyancourt
tout au long de la journée de vendredi
parce que là ils sont encadrés par leurs
professeurs et ils viennent avec leur
collège
et puis le samedi c'est ouvert aussi ça
permet de revenir avec les parents pour
qu'eux aussi puissent se faire une idée
des perspectives professionnelles qui
s'ouvre très bien ici un jeu l'emploi en
fait qu'ils aient ouvert donc aux jeunes
de l'emploi et de la mission locale donc
je connais pas parfaitement la règle du
jeu mais la mission locale reçoit plus
de 3000 jeunes tous les ans et donc de
18 à 25 ans et donc un certain nombre
d'entre eux sont en recherche d'emploi
vous savez aussi que on a les contrats
d'avenir qui ce qui se met en place que
la mission locale en a la responsabilité
donc voilà c'est aussi un moment où les
jeunes peuvent prendre contact avec la
mission locale
donc c'est un peu finalement très bien
orientée pour ne pas tomber dans le
chômage être être orientés être suivie
être accompagnées dans le présent avis
aussi envers la vie professionnelle
la nouveauté aussi cette année ses
preuves le forum de l'insertion
alors le forum de l'insertion c'est
l'espace le secteur d'action sociale de
trappes qui a souhaité le mettre en
place
et puis de le faire dans la dans le
cadre de cette semaine de l'emploi donc
voyez où on a un peu atone arias qui est
qui est important et donc ça s'adressera
plus particulièrement aux personnes en
rsa et réveiller enfin qu'il a pourront
rencontrer tous les partenaires de
l'insertion du territoire à la l'espace
de trappes
mais on peut noter aussi qu'il ya un
accueil pour les enfants pour leur
permettre de venir voilà parce que
savoir décision d'inviter pour les
femmes qui vous viennent de faire garder
il y aura une garderie oui alors pour
les chômeurs seniors il n'y a pas de
forum en tout cas pas cette année ils
sont évidemment invités à venir
donc on s'est rendu à la cité des
métiers qui organisait hier un atelier
spécifique pour les plus de 45 ans s'est
finalement bien de se préparer à des
entretiens futur mais également au forum
qui sont proposés dans cette semaine on
regarde son image à la cité des métiers
à trappes
on propose chaque semaine différents
ateliers pour les demandeurs d'emploi
ici on s'occupe d'un groupe un peu
particulier les plus de 45 ans d'après
la dares 20% des 54 mille 700 chômeurs
yvelinois ont plus de 50 ans passé un
certain âge il devient plus difficile de
retrouver un travail
j'étais un entretien btp on m'a dit vous
n'avez pas les deux pieds dans le béton
bon
ça sous-entend que vous n'êtes pas dans
le métier et puis un jeune peut-être
qu'il sera plus disponible que vous nous
coûtera peut-être moins cher voilà c'est
tout après il faut trouver des solutions
trouver des solutions c'est ce que
propose fasse un club d'entreprises qui
luttent contre l'exclusion
gilles l'animateur propose aux
participants de faire un tri dans leurs
compétences
objectif mettre en avant celles qui
répondent aux besoins du marché et qui
les différencie des autres de parler de
façon plus plus courte de mes
compétences oui ça ça va être utile en
effet mais bon j'ai quand même du boulot
avant d'arriver à ça pendant la semaine
de l'emploi qui démarre ce vendredi à
saint quentin en yvelines
clarisse pourra tenter de mettre en
application cette valorisation des
compétences si beaucoup de participants
ont déjà écumé des forums de l'emploi
sans succès gilles les pousse à
continuer seulement du demandeur
d'emploi c'est la pire des le pire des
parcours donc je leur dis oui allez dans
tout le salon
mais ne soyez pas triste si vous n'avez
pas eu la réponse instantanément pour
ses seniors retrouver un emploi prendra
du temps mais après un suivi un ciblage
des entreprises contactées 70% des
précédents participants ils sont arrivés
alors madame vilain on voit que
l'animateur souligner cette nécessité ce
nécessité pardon de sortir de l'
isolement est-ce que c'est finalement
aussi le rôle de la semaine de l'emploi
oui je pense que ça permet aux
demandeurs d'emploi aux jeunes d'avoir
un premier contact avec un recruteur
parce que la plupart rencontré à mon
avis ça permet d'acquérir une certaine
expérience et puis de sortir de cet
isolement qui finalement est vraiment la
plus grosse difficulté rencontrée par
les demandeurs d'emploi on sait qu'au
bout de six mois neuf mois un an de
chômage les contacts deviennent
difficiles et je crois que c'est
importante de garder ce lien
et ça c'est très important de venir
c'est très important merci beaucoup
on profite en fait la présence de jean
luc romero pour parler d'un autre sujet
qui est le concours de la jeune
entreprise ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire deux mots oui c'est une opération
que
que mène la maison de l'entreprise
depuis quelques années maintenant c'est
un concours se tient tous les deux ans
et il est ouvert aux à la fois porteurs
de projets donc aux entreprises tout
jeune mais également d'entreprises qui
ont trois ou quatre ans d'activité
donc nous avons plusieurs prix et ce
concours est organisé comme pour nombre
d'actions que nous menons dans le cadre
de la maison d'entreprise ce concours
est organisé avec un nombre conséquent
de partenaires des structures la fois
publiques et privées qui qui qui propose
des prix cette année nous avons réussi à
mobiliser environ 50000 euros de prix
mais ses conséquences est contestée
absolument et l'idée c'est de faire
ressortir pour à la fois la catégorie
jeune entreprise à la fois pour la
catégorie porteurs de projets le fait
ressortir deux ou trois lauréats et de
manière à mettre en valeur des projets
qui peuvent être intéressants également
pour le territoire de 50 en 2009 et au
delà de cette aide financière est ce
qu'il ya derrière un suivi oui bien sûr
mais après ça entraînant dans le cadre
des missions classiques de la maison de
l'entreprise c'est à dire que non
seulement nous essayons d'appuyer les
porteurs de projets dans leur démarche
de création mais notre rôle c'est aussi
de les appuyer dans leurs démarches de
développement
donc on met en place bien évidemment un
accompagnement et et on développe
également des outils on a régulièrement
parlé sur votre plateau d'outils de
financement
c'est un sujet qui est qui et qui est
particulièrement important aujourd'hui
donc au travers notamment de ce
dispositif de financement que nous avons
mis en place il ya quatre ans maintenant
on réfléchit à un élargissement
justement pour permettre aux entreprises
au delà de la troisième ou cinquième
année d'activité d'avoir accès à des
financements de manière plus rapide et
plus pratique
juste pour conclure est ce que vous
auriez peut-être un un beau parcours à
nous raconter d'une entreprise lauréate
oui depuis depuis tant d'années on a eu
de beaux lauréats
de mémoire rapidement on a eu il ya
quelques quelques années a porté le
projet qui a fait grossir son entreprise
dans le domaine du pétrole en
particulier et qu'il ya quelques années
maintenant la chance d'être cotées en
bourse donc c'était un beau succès dont
on avait la fierté sur le territoire de
saint quentin
mais voilà on a effectivement de beaux
projets de nature totalement différente
il est important peut-être de préciser
que c'est ouvert effectivement des
projets qui peuvent être les projets il
ya l'innovation des projets
technologiques mais pas seulement on est
ravi également de pouvoir faire la
promotion de l'activité artisanale ou de
prestation de services plus modestes
parce qu'on parle de l'emploi tout à
l'heure elles sont de toutes façons
génératrice d'emplois un moment donné
donc c'est intéressant pour le
territoire
il ya un mois je trouve ya un mot qu'on
comprend bien ce soir c'est le mot
accompagnement à sa compagne mans le
demandeur d'emploi accompagnement aussi
du créateur une journée accompagné plus
on est aidé et plus on peut sortir soit
situation difficile soit elle soit bien
évolué comme vous parler de cette
société maintenant côté ont coté en
bourse
ceux qui souhaiteraient participer donc
les inscriptions sont ouvertes
absolument c'est jusqu'au 22 avril tout
à fait donc il ya plus d'informations
sur le site de l'agglomération et les
résultats on les aura résultat courant
juin
nous aurons donc une cérémonie de remise
de prix en principe ça se trouve au
cinéma ugc de saint quentin en yvelines
et en présence des institutionnels et
politiques du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
on suivra avec la tension évidemment sur
téléphiles puisqu'on reçoit souvent les
lauréats de ce fameux concours merci
venu en plateau à l'éclair on continue
avec quelques infos en plus et une bonne
nouvelle dans ce climat morose
économique
allez une bonne nouvelle la hausse des
créations d'entreprises en résine et en
2012 exactement douze mille deux cent
douze entreprises exactement ont été
créés dans les yvelines en 2012 selon
les derniers chiffres publiés par l'
agence pour la création d'entreprise
c'est tout de même une hausse de 3,4
pour cent par rapport à 2011 alors que
le niveau stagne au niveau national
alors maintenant direction les
clayes-sous-bois menaces sur les
commerces de proximité de la rue maury
jouer et c'est très sérieux un oui tout
à fait le promoteur immobilier franco
suisse chercherait à acheter certains
commerces en bas de la rue maurice jouer
aux clayes-sous-bois le promoteur aurait
déjà réussi à avoir quelques promesses
de vente ou risquent donc de voir les
commerces de proximité disparaissent en
tout cas du côté de la mairie
ils affirment ne pas du tout être au
courant du dossier donc on va suivre ça
suivre avant goût il ya un nouveau
président pour l'association dès
commerçants et une idée nouvelle aussi
oui il s'appelle bruno chennevières à
chennevières si je pense bien pardon qui
agent immobilier dont il prend la tête
de l'association dès commerçants et
artisans de rambouillet et il arrive
avec un projet ce qui est de créer un
site internet réservé au e-commerce pour
les commerçants des villes et mon petit
doigt me dit que peut-être on pourrait
prochainement le recevoir dans la
chronique échos voilà on y est
maintenant la junte à quelques dates à
retenir donc et bien pour l'agenda on va
évidemment rappelé quelques dates clés
de la semaine de l'emploi
donc on rappelle qu'elle s'est pas assez
du 15 au 23 février
la nouveauté de cette édition c'est le
forum de l'insertion qui se passe demain
c'est de 9h30 à 16h les secteurs
d'action à trappes qui sont sociales
donc c'est un forum qui réservé aux
bénéficiaires du rsa forum plus ouvert
qui consacrait lui à l'intérim
ce sera lundi 18 février de 13h à 17h
des infos seront donnés au sur le
travail intérimaire et des recruteurs
locaux seront présents donc ça se passe
à prismes aux prises mais il encourt une
dernière date les assises de l'emploi
qui sont ouverts à toutes les
entreprises sur le thème comment
pérenniser vos emplois en période de
crise et ça ça se déroulera mardi 19 de
17 heures à 19 heures à la salle du
conseil à trappes
et puis évidemment pour avoir plus
d'informations et à connaître tout
simplement les autres dates de cette
semaine où vous donne rendez vous sur le
site de l'agglomération où une page
spéciale y est consacré merci car à nos
invités on va continuer on va quitter le
maintenant l'économie on va parler
culture et on va se rendre à la maison
phénix à montigny le bretonneux
poursuivre une exposition qui signait
par muriel schwarz est une autodidacte
qui a choisi l'aquarelle pour forme
d'expression on regarde faire passer
l'émotion
travail et l'interprétation pour ses
voyages en aquarelle
c'est le pari de muriel schwarz ini
monteyne pour sa toute première
exposition à la maison félix de montigny
le bretonneux
passionné d'aquarelles cet artiste en
herbe part à la conquête de ses tout
premiers public
j'ai toujours aimé dessiner et mais
c'est vrai que cette le côté doux pastel
et le rendu des aquarelles me plaisait
bien et c'est comme ça j'ai choisi de me
de prendre des cours de nous spécialiser
un petit peu là dedans au total 43
toiles sont exposées travail de
reproduction d'après des tableaux mais
aussi des photos pour un rendu plus
original enfants sous couleurs pastel
portrait de pays d'ailleurs
muriel choir s'inspire de tous les
supports pour laisser vivre son art je
trouve très très belle très varié il ya
vraiment de tout pour tous les goûts
sur place la peintre laisse libre cours
à sa création
prochaine étape l'abstrait l'artiste
souhaite gommer les supports pour
laisser place à son imagination
une exposition elle se poursuit jusqu'au
17 février
voilà et pour finir ce 7,8 du 14 février
de la saint valentin un nouveau détour
par les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines pour savoir quel est votre
programme pour ce soir etes-vous
romantique
je vais l'échelle fleuriste je vais
aller offrir ce bouquet de fleurs à la
fleuriste qui est là de la part de son
ami et moi du coup je vais prendre un
bouquet pour ma femme simplement un
petit repas un peu mieux que d'habitude
c'est tout riu tous ses choix sa stupide
de dire à la personne qu'on a acquis
avec qui on est pourquoi en laine
seulement un jour se soit rien mais je
pense qu'un médium assure un petit repas
en amoureux pour moi elle saint valentin
je suis pas d'amoureux donc je la fait
tout seul dans un petit dîner tranquille
à la maison achetée une bonne petite
gâterie la petit plaisir et puis un
petit repas sympa voilà c'est tout la
raison le plaisir c'est encore sida
mieux 7,8 est terminé merci de votre
attention
demain vous retrouvez wilfried récit
pour le 7-8 week-end un retour sur
l'actualité de la semaine écoulée
mais avant de ceux qui déjeunent résiste
pas à vous faire entendre ces quelques
notes de musique les paroles sont
signées du poète louis aragon qui a
longtemps habité avec sa compagne elsa
triolet les yvelines à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines couple
rappelez-vous avait un moulin qui lui
servait de résidence secondaire
l'interprétation est bien entendu signée
de jean ferrat excellente soirée à vous
et puis un clin d'oeil tout particulier
aux amoureux et aux amoureuses qui se
reconnaîtront en filière musique
que serais je sans toi camarade
serais je sans toi bien que nombreux
lots
7 heures
au cas d'orange bon
en serait sans doute
ce balbutiement
loupé